just when you thought it was safe to go
back to work in Congress it turns out
that there's another staffer filming gay
sex tapes at the capital I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show lots of
dysfunction between the Sexes Cameron
Diaz wants married couples to sleep not
only in separate rooms but in separate
homes we'll get to that in just a little
bit uh we will also get to the
dysfunction within the Sexes I suppose
after another gay sex tape emerges in
Washington DC at the US capital I wish
we didn't have to talk about that but we
do and when you want to talk you got to
check out P talk right now go to Pur
talk.com /ns are you traveling for
Christmas if so your talk has you
covered because they just added
International roaming to over 30
countries that's right whether you are
making calls on a beach in the Bahamas
on the steps of Buckingham Palace or at
your Villa in Santorini you can dial
away here's the best part no rate
increase Pure Talk still saves the
average family almost $1,000 a year with
plans starting at just 20 bucks a month
Pure Talk is the gift that keeps on
giving they put you on America's most
Dependable 5G Network the coverage is
second to none stop dragging your feet
switch to P talk a veteran-owned
Wireless company with Simply the Best Us
customer service team now with
international roaming to over 30
countries go to Pur
talk.com kwes to make the switch you
will also save an additional 50% off
your first month that is Pur talk.com
kwes to start saving on wireless today
Pure Talk is simply smart marter
Wireless last week a staffer for some
democrat
Senator was caught film I think I'm the
only show in America that did not post
screenshots of this in his show or on
his Twitter page and I don't no one
needs to see the screenshots but it was
pretty gross and uh the staffer then
said that he was being persecuted for
who he loves of course he was not being
persecuted for who he loves I'm not
quite sure that what he was doing in
that video would be described as love uh
he was certainly being persecuted for
How He Loves because that isn't love and
he's if he's trying to love he's doing
it the wrong way and definitely doing it
in the wrong place where he loves I
guess is another issue namely the Senate
Judiciary hearing room so just a week
after that turns out there is another
Congressional sex tape involving a
couple of
fellas this one apparently circulated on
Snapchat last year but for those of us
who are are not in those circles we're
only finding out about it now
conveniently after this other uh sex
tape this is from the story of a user
going by Adam J uh recordings of this
were viewed by semaphor and mercifully
not by all of us uh but semaphor says
that the videos featured a man inside a
house office
building uh doing something alone this
is a family show I'm going to try to
clean it up you know uh he was doing
what Woody Allen referred to as sleeping
with someone you love uh and then there
was also another one with a dude with
two two men uh engaged in something
unfortunate uh the participants faces
are not visible in any of this
material and then on top of that on top
of that a slightly different but still
related Scandal Joe Biden's press
secretary Michael L Roo was just forced
out of the White House after he
apparently tried quote tried to take gay
dates to his room on a secure floor of
the hotel where the president was
staying during a NATO Summit in Madrid
so when we say dates we're not talking
about this is a man who had been
cultivating some sort of relationship
over some weeks and months no it was a
guy who like went on an app or something
or met a guy at a bar and this this
press secretary for the first lady of
the United States bring some random dude
back to the secured floor where the
president of the United States is
staying uh to go engage in weird stuff
that apparently happens in places other
than the US capital i
I am calling for a complete and total
shutdown of homosexual political
staffers with iPhones until we figure
out what the hell is going on okay I am
a complete and total shutdown we should
not be reading this many headlines
within the span of two weeks at very
high levels of the government that is
really weird man what is driving this
this is completely insane behavior let's
start with the most anod of the
behaviors this dude working for Joe
Biden who decides it's a smart idea
during a NATO Summit you're there
working for the first lady you're with
the president you're with the entire
Secret Service and you decide it's a
good idea to pick up some random dude in
a foreign country and go back and do
creepy weird stuff in your hotel room on
a floor with the president what what
kind of
Insanity would have to have taken over
your mind and soul to convince you that
was a good idea you're going to give up
a promising political career with one of
the most enviable jobs in politics
you're working right there for the first
family in the White House and you give
that up to do weird creepy sex stuff
with some Rando Spaniard what has to
take over your mind you you've got a job
in the US capital working for a member
of the House of Representatives or a
senator and you decide it's a really
good idea to not only engage in creepy
actions that would obviously be caused
for immediate termination and actions
which are in themselves extremely
humiliating but you're going to film it
and send it around and you think that's
going to be fine no one's going to trace
it back to you even though you're on
camera committing the actions you the
the guy who was working for the Democrat
Senator he posted all sorts of weird
creepy sex stuff all over his social
media not only after he was hired even
before he was hired he somehow still got
the job what is taking over these
people's minds to convince them to do
something not only that is gross and
immoral but that is just so stupid
that's so profoundly foolish and that is
guaranteed in in the long run to lose
you your job and career and to humiliate
you at the national level I'll give you
the answer I know exactly what it is
we've been talking about it for 2 weeks
is porn that's what's doing it to these
people that is what is melting these
people's brains and the reason I know
that is because I read the mailbag the
reason I know that is I read surveys and
statistics on porn usage which is 90%
plus among men because I read the
statistics that show that the average
age or the median age of first exposure
to porn is something like 11 and then I
read the mailbag and I hear from people
not only the libs who brag about how
addicted to porn they are but even
conservatives who say I've been
struggling with this since I was a kid
or or a teenager and it's really awful
and I keep trying to fix it and I I
can't most people are are addicted to
this stuff at least among men I hope not
among women but even the rates
apparently of viewership among women
have gone
up and it it melts people's brains it
warps their perception of reality it
like any drug is is just totally warping
their their risk analysis like a like a
crackhead who's trying to score that
they totally ignore risk that they
engage in Reckless dangerous behavior
that almost always redounds to their
disadvantage and there's the they're
literally filming porn in this case
right in in the case of these two dudes
the Senate guy and the Congressional guy
they were the reason I know porn is at
the heart of this is they weren't just
engaging in creepy sex acts in the
capital they were producing pornography
and then they were disseminating that to
other people so it's not even that this
was just uh something they wanted to
keep for their own posterity you know a
little momento of of their romp at the
capital part of whatever was driving
them was the fact that they would be
viewed by other people on a screen how
did this dude in NATO how did this Joe
Biden press secretary meet that random
guy maybe they met at a bar it could be
statistically though what's most likely
is they did it on one of these swipe
apps it's it's a major problem
okay because it is causing people to
become enslaved to one particular desire
you can easily become enslaved to any
Vice and sin if you if you're a Booz
hound and and you drink out of
moderation what happens you think you're
really free you think you're really
liberated you can do whatever you want
but in the moment that you break those
bounds of moderation the moment that you
engage in mortal sin and cultivate that
Vice what happens you become a slave you
become owned by that sin you become a
slave to booze or you could become a
slave to drugs or you could become a
slave to gluttony to food or you could
become a slave to Pride to vanity or in
this case you become a slave to your
lusts and so you do things that any
rational person knows is completely
insane you damage your life you become a
national laughing stock like all of
these guys have you lose your career for
what to do some embarrassing degrading
action on camera for other people how
sad and how pathetic is it how pathetic
is it for us as a country that we have
to talk about sex this much that the
libs will say why are the conservatives
so obsessed with sex we're not the ones
filming the stuff in the capital we're
not the ones picking up random dudes
while we're press secretary for Joe
Biden we're not the ones changing all
the sexual rules trying to redefine
marriage trying to put dudes in the
women's bathroom trying to put porn in
the hands of kindergarteners we're not
doing that we're the on saying saying
hey whoo chill man it's the libs who are
the aggressors in the sexual Revolution
it's the libs who are the aggressors in
the culture war and it's pathetic it's
very shameful for them and it's annoying
for us that we a once great nation
supposedly the global hegemon have to
spend all of our time talking about
genitals it's ridiculous it's sad it's
pathetic there are other things in the
world and if we want to be a great
nation again we're going to need to
focus on some of those things but you
can't focus on those things when your
brain is so melted by porn that that in
in our nation's capital we have to spend
our time investigating who is filming
pornography in the Senate hearing room
or we we need to spend time
investigating what really is a man and
what really is a woman so that we can
have a national debate over whether
dudes should be allowed into your little
daughter's bathroom at a at a public
pool pathetic no Nation will be great if
that is what we have to
do but but the problem is you do have to
address some of these things because if
we don't understand basic facts of life
if we if we can't agree on basic facts
of human nature we can't have a poity we
can't talk to one another we can't
deliberate we can't even speak we don't
we don't even speak the same language
anymore and if we don't overcome our
most basic appetites and passions then
we won't be capable of rational thought
or a rational will or being a great
nation absolutely pathetic now I'm
hoping I think I see a little glimmer of
of light here and it actually comes to
me via Tik
Tok
but all things can be used for good I
suppose in some way uh I think that the
conservative constellation which is that
reality ultimately reasserts itself in
the end we're beginning to see this
breakr in the form of a bisexual
eastsider from Los Angeles which we'll
get to in one second first though we
need to take a break really fast to
discuss the break fast podcast there are
a lot of podcasts out there most of
those podcasts are people talking about
their intimate lives complaining about
how America's racist or how religion is
evil now outside of the daily wire it is
tough to find creative handsome podcasts
that are both enjoyable and intellectual
and extremely charismatic and even sexy
some would say well luckily there's a
great new Catholic podcast that I just
heard about the podcast is called Break
fast and is the perfect mix of
entertaining and spiritual Catholic
content breakfast explains the Catholic
faith through the prison of food drink
landmarks and architecture the Catholic
faith is so interwoven in our culture
that we often don't even realize it the
word breakfast for example comes from
Catholics breaking the fast after
morning Mass did you know Sushi tempura
has its roots in the Catholic faith I
didn't know that or how champagne was
actually created by a Catholic monk
named Dom Perino I assumed it was made
by a priest named father Cristal but I
was wrong it's it's a monk named D Peron
the show's creators saw the need for a
podcast that is engaging and accessible
to everyone of any faith or none at all
breakfast is not just a random
assortment of Catholic related facts it
covers hard-hitting topics who will make
you Ponder the important questions each
episode of breakfast is around 20
minutes long super easy download it
right now on Apple Spotify or wherever
you get your podcasts a liberal feminist
Eastside bisexual gal has gone viral on
Tik Tok
for relating her shock her awe at her
own reaction to going on a date with a
bro I went on a date this week and I
felt the feminism leaving my body I live
on the east side of LA and if you don't
know what that means it's sort of like
the artsier part of La you know it's
it's people say it's like Brooklyn and
New York like so I go on dates with a
lot of men and women who you know live
over here there's always a negotiation
about who pays and that's great I like
to pay for people all that but what I
will
say is that I sort of fell into going on
a date with the most guys guy I've ever
been on a date with and he's from West
West you know Santa Monica he's a bro
right a GU guy is usually not my type
like I cannot remember the last time
that I went on a date with like a
straight Bros bro you know what I'm
saying but it befell me it befell me in
an organic fashion so I'm on this date
with this guy and the thing about a guy
guys he's putting his card down he's
paying for everything and I really just
it sort of activated something feral in
me I'm not going to lie we went to like
another bar and he went he was going to
go to the bathroom so I was getting
prepared to pay for our drinks cuz he's
been paying all night of course I'm
going to pay for the next round but as
he's going to leave for the bathroom he
turns to me and he hands me his credit
card and he goes here's my card get us
whatever
it might be time for me to get away from
all these you know liberal snowflakes on
the east
side I love it I love this video I love
her take there's a little touch of irony
here when she uses that phrase at the
end these liberal snowflakes but that
little touch of irony is speaking to a
big truth and she's actually feeling it
and reality remains
undefeated love it this is the this is
the consolation for conservatives the
whole culture is against us the
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness and high places that rule
this world they are all turned against
us all the time but here's but reality
is still there there is still an order
to the cosmos there is still Justice
there is actually and truth and goodness
and Beauty are not overwhelmed they are
not overshadowed
reality remains undefeated I love it
think about this video some people are
attacking her
some very misguided conservatives are
attacking this poor girl I think I find
her very
Charming but they're attacking her
because all she's saying she's happy
about is that he paid for the date she's
not saying she liked the conversation
she's not saying he was good-looking
she's not she just she liked that he
paid for dinner and when he went to hit
the head passed her his credit card and
said hey could you order the next round
of drinks get
whatever oh she's just a gold digger no
no no this is a poor girl who deserves
our sympathy and encouragement and she's
typical in this culture could you
imagine could you imagine for the the
normal people listening to this
show how far our sexual relations have
fallen I don't mean you know Saucy stuff
I'm talking about actually how men and
women relate to one another that this
woman for the first time in her life
perhaps had a guy buy her a drink and
she's floored by it this woman what
she's in her 20s I don't know how old
exactly a guy bought her a drink and she
can't get over it she has to take to the
internet to explain to the masses what
this unusual experience is
like this is Baseline stuff this guy did
not lay his coat out on a puddle for her
to walk over this guy did not send
flowers to her home or her office this
guy did not I don't even know if he open
the door of the car he just bought her
some drinks and
dinner and she just melts of course she
melts this this whole
attitude you know I'm an easts side
feminist I live in Los FES La whatever
I'm hip and cool I'm kind of a lesbian
you know like I'm cool I was cool in
college I'm I'm a lesbian like all all
of that goes away and she she's laughing
about it but of course it does it's not
even her fault she probably went to some
stupid liberal arts college that don't
actually doesn't actually teach you the
liberal arts that just encourages you to
like wear silly sweaters and date all
sorts of members of both sexes and study
grievance and then move to LA and become
whatever kind of artist she is okay she
had a disadvantage from the
beginning is this the first time she's
ever met some kind of Finance bro
wearing a a Patagonia zipup
vest with some kind of button-down
collar who who even has a credit card is
this this might be the first time that
she hasn't met some guy who's just you
know vaguely soy kind of Pumped full of
estrogen has an unkempt beard and asks
her to pay for dinner this is and so I
don't I don't knock her for it she's
discovered something new and you know
what she it's not that she's discovered
the Westside guy with a job and a line
of credit it's not just that she's
discovered a date what a date is
supposed to look like in the most basic
degree she's discovered reality just a
little T just a little hint of reality
in a culture that has heaped mud and
dirt and obscured reality she's just
seen like a little glimmer of it and
she's excited by that and I'm excited by
that too I encourage her that's great
keep going keep going
lady I'm I'm with you I'm cheering you
on now turning back to
Washington and but but keeping on with
women Nikki Haley
was asked Point Blank will you consider
being Donald Trump's vice president here
is her non- answer going talk about you
as vice president and I know what you're
going to say I don't play for a second I
got it I've I've seen the line and it's
authentic I get it but Ronda santz has
ruled it out says no way I'm not going
to do it okay are you going to rule it
out I don't play for a second I knew you
going say it's offensive When anybody
says that oh you know she wants to be
vice president you you don't do
something like this to be vice versa you
don't sacrifice emotionally mentally
physically with your family everything
to come in for second that's not me I've
never done second a day in my life I'm
not going to start now I'm doing this
because we have a country to save
everybody knows it our country is in
disarray and the world is on fire and I
don't trust anybody else to fix it and
I'm determined to get that done and
we're going to get it done and the
people want us to get that done you can
feel it and that's why you're seeing us
move in the poles is because they're TR
they're tired with me there's no drama
there are no vendettas there's no
whining it's just work it's what I've
always done as work but you're not going
to rule it out be you're not going to
rule it out I'm it's not even a
conversation and it doesn't matter what
candidate wants me to answer it I don't
play for a second I don't know what more
I can say than than to get them to
understand
that you could say
no right I mean I really like Nikki and
this is probably the best answer answer
she could give because the moment she
says I would consider it then it gives
Trump an opening to attack her or it it
makes her look like she's not really
running for the job so she she gave the
politician answer that she I guess had
to give but the fact that she didn't say
no I will not be Trump's VP as desandis
did means that she would be Trump's VP
of course of course she
would but the reason this is a smart
answer is Nikki
knows that the only way she's going to
be Trump's VP is to be
strong Nikki knows she's not going to be
Trump's Top Choice as a VP because she
worked for him and then she turned on
him and then she cozied up to him again
and then she kind of she said I wouldn't
run if he's running but then she did run
and so she she knows that she's probably
on the outs of trump world right now
she's not going to be top of the list
unless she can consolidate a large part
of the GOP behind her she's already
starting to do that she's got the coke
nut work she's got she's now running
second and a pretty strong second in New
Hampshire she's getting the
establishment types to start coming
behind her she knows that's her Lane
it's not enough to put her over the edge
not a chance it's not even CL her
surging in New Hampshire is still a
country mile behind Donald Trump but if
she can amass the support of a large
part of the
GOP want to say 30% maybe I don't know
35% of the
GOP 40% would be amazing for her but 30
or 35 would probably get it done then
you might be able to have like a Reagan
Bush type of situation where Reagan
represents the conservatives Bush
represents the moderates in the
establishment they come together for a
ticket to unify the party and they win
in 1980 and in 1984 even though they
came from totally different ends of the
party I don't think they liked each
other very much George HW Bush actually
coined the term voodoo economics to make
fun of Ronald Reagan's Economic Policy
during the primary it wasn't a Democrat
who came up with that term even though
it's today used by democrats it was
George HW Bush but they came together to
unify the party I think that's what
Nikki is trying to do here but Nikki
knows the only way out is through she's
got to go through this process she's got
to get Dan santis out of the race she's
got to get christe out of the race she's
got to V probably doesn't M they hate
each other so much it's not as though
getting him out of the race is going to
help her numbers necessarily but she's
got to consolidate the anti-trump vote
she's doing a pretty good job at it
looks good for her now when you want to
look good you got to check out Jus cell
right now go to jus /ns today there is a
lot to be stressed about during the
Christmas season stress and lack of
sleep can easily cause those pesky under
eye bags good news is you never have to
worry about that when you have genell
skin care from now until Christmas
genell's most popular package has a
special discount just for our listeners
at Jus cell.com
kwes treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute best skincare in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness and sagging
jawline will disappear right before your
eyes with genus cell's most popular
collection genus cell promises immediate
effects you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed or your money
back Jus cell made Christmas come early
this year they sent down a ton of
products for the entire office everyone
is raving about their under eye cream it
works wonders plus included in every
most popular package is your free
hyaluronic acid serum for skin hydration
and restoration you deserve to look and
feel your best this Christmas season go
to genucell.com right now get this
incredible holiday discount every pre
order instantly upgraded to a free
express shipping jus.com
kwes today my favorite comment yesterday
is from Kila civa 6746 who says I love
how they say stop breathing or you will
die but I feel the best response to that
is okay you first right of when the
environmentalists say your breath is
destroying the world you've got to stop
breathing you say okay you first when
they push for assisted suicide you say
okay you first when they push for
abortion you say okay well you're a
former fetus you first
when they talk about overpopulation you
say okay there's too many people you you
you deal with it you take the first step
then then we'll hear about this but it's
never about them the
overpopulation always means that there
are too many of the other guy it's the
the importance of abortion is always
that someone else's kids needs to
go not them not them speaking
of the likelihood or unlikelihood of a
trump president
presidency distressing new poll out of
yugov America
finds that most Americans approve of
Donald Trump getting kicked off the
ballot in
Colorado there's a new poll found that
54% of Americans approve of kicking
Trump off the ballot in Colorado that
includes 24% of Republicans so there you
have it by the way there is that
anti-trump lane 24% of people 24% of
Republicans would happily go to any
non-trump candidate whether that's going
to be Dan santis whether that's going to
be Nikki Haley whether that's Chris
Christie whoever they just hate Trump
that much and then the non-trump
candidate might be able to pry away
another 5% another maybe even another
10% almost a quarter of Republicans
happy that Trump has kicked off that
ballot and most Americans that's bad
democracy will not work under those
circumstances it
can't I don't think that anyone is
particularly interested in democracy
working at this point the Democrats
obviously are not they hate democracy
and that's why they're kicking Trump off
the ballot because they don't think that
people ought to have the right to vote
for the popular candidate they've made
their opposition to democracy very very
clear even a lot of Republicans
though the Republicans are much more in
favor of democracy than the Democrats
are but Republicans wisely have have
shared the fears of the founding fathers
which is that democracy can Decay into
mob rule very very quickly and for most
of History it's been considered not the
best but the very worst form of of
government now it has worked more or
less well in America at different times
but democracy
requires that that both sides respect
the right of the other to have a chance
at winning elections that both
sides accept that the other is
politically
legitimate so even if we lose it's okay
the system endures or even if we win
we're not going to be imprisoned by well
we're not going to be prevented from
winning we're not going to be prevented
from taking office
whatever and and we don't really have
that the Democrats were the first to
chip away at that very clearly they've
if you just look at elections in the
last 100 years they are Far and Away the
more likely to deny elections and to you
know profane our sacred temples of
democracy or whatever but Republicans to
some degree too are skeptical of these
things like in 2020 when the Democrats
changed all the rules to favor them in
the weeks and months before the election
in some cases unconstitutionally like in
the case of Pennsylvania we're a little
skeptical of the elections now too but
in any case if most people believe that
it
is acceptable or preferable or downright
good for some partisan appointed or
elected official to keep a popular
candidate off the ballot to prevent the
people from voting for the candidate of
their
choice democracy is not long for this
country which is is natural I mean pus
the ancient political writer talked
about this many moons
ago regimes
Decay they're good kinds of regimes
monarchy aristocracy and democracy
they're bad kinds of those same type of
regimes which would be tyranny oligarchy
and MOB Rule and the regimes as they
Decay they transform one into the
other we might be transforming now and
it it might be inevitable you know the
Roman Republic transforms into the Roman
Empire and in our modern Republican and
Democratic age we we look on this as a
very terrible thing Caesar for the for
the first time in history really has
been cast as the bad guy in that
exchange but if you think Julius Caesar
is bad just wait till you hear about the
Roman senate if you think the Roman
Empire was bad just wait until you hear
about the late stage Republic things had
gotten really bad and decadent and
debauched and the people had very little
say in their government and there was
very little accountability and that's
that's what brought on the political
conditions for that kind of change well
if we keep seeing polls like this
there's going to be a political change
here in the US as well uh speaking of
the presidency this is a big story that
no one's heard about Washington Post is
reporting that the FBI has James Biden
this is Joe Biden's brother on tape
negotiating business involving his
brother the president of the United
States the FBI has these tapes so which
means that they were spying on the guy
which means that they've been
investigating them for a long
time the FBI which initially denied
Hunter's lap top which has carried water
for the Democrats we're now finding out
now they they know what's going on with
the Biden family they we know that the
Biden business earned 24 million bucks
between 2015 and 2019 is that for James
Biden's expertise is that for Hunter
Biden's expertise I don't think so
business used more than 20 shell
companies sounds pretty dodgy to me not
very straightforward business and
Associates sold the Biden brand what
does this tell us doesn't tell us
anything new about Biden we knew all
this stuff tells us a little bit about
the FBI tells us a little bit about the
American deep state which is just
another term for the liberal
establishment the entrenched
bureaucracy we know that the Washington
Post is mobbed up with intelligence
we've known that since deep throat and
and the Nixon tapes the Watergate
scandal Washington Post got this story
from intelligence obviously tells you
one of two things either the story is
legit probably is because we know about
Joe Biden's corruption we have the
receipts or at the very least it tells
you that the the intelligence agencies
want people to believe that the story is
legit the Intel agencies are not in the
business of protecting Joe Biden anymore
that's what it tells you either way very
very bad news for Joe
Biden either he's he's associated with
these crimes and it looks bad for him
and his family or the Intel agencies
which to quote Chuck Schumer can get you
nine ways from Sunday they've turned on
Biden they don't like him anymore
speaking of the establishment papers
turning that the New York Times is
turning on Claudine gay who's the
Harvard president so the Harvard
president you know has plagiarized
everything up to an including thank you
notes for coming to dinner and uh
Harvard tried to dismiss this the woman
has basically no academic record she has
11 published papers it's pathetic it's
nothing but I think everybody knows why
she is in that position why the white
lady who was running upen was fired for
saying exactly the same thing that
Claudine gay a black lady lady said
before Congress on the same occasion but
Claud and gay gets to keep her job
because she checks some Dei boxes well
now all of a sudden the media which had
been quiet about this starts reporting
New York Times Harvard finds more
instances of duplicative language in the
president's work she's faced growing
criticism not only of her response to
anti-Semitism but also her scholarship
this is
great why why is the establishment going
after Claudine gay now I think in part
it's because these New York Times
writers and editors don't want their
degrees to get watered down the the the
press used to be run by ordinary normal
people it was kind of a bluecollar job
you know shoes on the pavement tracking
down a story in recent years it's become
a a very elite job and the people who
fill up the New York Times offices now
are graduates of places like Princeton
and Stanford and Yale and yes Harvard
and I think some of them don't want
their Alma moer to become a laughing
stock cuz they want that that degree to
continue to carry Prestige uh also
because of the dogged work of
Christopher rufo the right-wing think
tanker and journalist and more than
anything perhaps political operative who
has really really pushed this story keep
the pressure up this is a great new
phase in the war on Harvard uh it looks
like we might be able to claim this
political
scalp
now we've reached my favorite time of
the week which is the mailbag but first
I got to tell you about a new kids ENT
company that has made Saturday mornings
great again with brand new episodes of
kids shows on bent key we brought back
Saturday morning cartoons tomorrow
morning get ready for 17 new episodes
premiering on bent key including Mabel
mlay a fun throwback to Mr Rogers along
with new episodes of clangers Yeti Tales
runes truck games how ridiculous and
more it's 100% ad free speaking of free
you can unlock all that beny has to
offer with a free 14-day trial simply
use the code unlock when you sign up at
Ben key.com to start streaming today you
won't want to miss the Gus plus us
Christmas special stream streaming now
exclusively on bent key if you're not a
bent key member yet this is your
invitation to try bent key for free
that's right just in time for Christmas
we are giving everyone a 14-day trial of
Premium kids content bent key unlock the
new adventure and kids entertainment
today bent key.com code unlock code that
you need to start your 14-day free trial
is
unlock before I get to the mailbag I
have to hit the story from Cameron Diaz
Cameron Diaz just came out and said we
need to normalize couple sleeping not
only in separate bedrooms but in
separate homes and everyone has been
dragging her for this the only defense I
want to make of Cameron Diaz here is
that Aristocrats have been doing this
forever Aristocrats have been sleeping
in separate bedrooms forever the royal
family sleeps in separate bedrooms the
queen Queen Elizabeth and Prince Philip
would sleep in separate bedrooms there's
something to that I think where the the
disconnect is here is that uh people
sleeping in separate homes is a little
bit clinical I'm reminded of a line from
Robert Frost which is U from a poem
departmental the line is uh it couldn't
be called ungentle but how thoroughly
departmental and what this comes from I
suspect is not an old aristocratic sense
that we want to have our proper spaces
and you know be together in this very
well-ordered uh high class kind of um
schedule but it comes from a demand for
individualism you know it actually comes
from the totally the opposite the the
old
aristocratic uh order for sleeping and
behavior and living came from the notion
that we don't have really very much
privacy that everything is sort of
public and we don't have a ton of
individualism that we express however we
please but we have duty and we have
honor and we have to behave in a certain
proper way we have to wear a certain
clothing and eat dinner at a certain
time and behave in a certain way with
members of the opposite sex up to an
including our spouse what Cameron Diaz
is talking about here is expressive
individualism which is I want my own
space I want my own thing and and maybe
my husband can come and visit me when
it's convenient for me that probably not
a great idea separate bedrooms can be
nice because you our spouses always
steal the sheets but uh if if one had to
choose I think it's probably good to
cuddle up next to your honey and uh Tamp
down the individualism that threatens to
destroy our civilization this mailbag is
sponsored by Pure Talk go to P talk.com
kwes to save an additional 50% off your
first month take it away hello Michael
you talk a lot about practicing virtue
on your show for good
reason I have developed a lot of bad
habits over the years and no matter how
hard I try I always seem to fall for
Temptation whether it's too much TV or
mindless internet scrolling anger
impatience selfishness and so on I will
do good for a short period of time and
always fall into these viices again it
seems that I'm either doing really well
or doing really bad there's really no in
between my question is do you believe
change is really possible I pray and go
to confession but I just always seem to
fall back into these bad
habits I really want to change but I
feel that at this point I'm just damaged
goods and have little to no hope left
and I know one shouldn't despair but I
always seem to just lose control at some
point and plugge hen first into these
vices I hope you can offer some advice
and thanks for all you do and may God
bless you and your family for kind thank
you uh I don't want to hear I know one
shouldn't despair
butt I don't want to hear the butt no
buttheads around here okay yes do not
despair it's a sin hope is a theological
virtue and something you are commanded
to do so cut it out okay uh yes you're
you're committing all sorts of sins and
vices and you fall into it you mentioned
confession so I'll give you a more
robust mackerel snapping papist take on
this sort of thing Avail yourself of the
sacraments and confession is very
important uh make sure you're having
you're giving a good confession the
number of times you commit a certain sin
the severity of the sin this details
specifics about the sin uh the reason to
do that is well one you don't want to
commit sacrilege by hiding something you
don't want to just be totally vague and
then just go along committing all the
sins forever be very specific about it
also
because we believe Catholics believe
Christians believed for all Christians
believe for a very long time and most
Christians still today believe that
there are different kinds of Graces
there's sanctifying Grace which is
active within our souls this is what we
talk about when we say we're in a state
of grace when we commit a mortal sin
which is a sin that is grave and
deliberate you know a sin that involves
a conscious choice and an action of our
will then we sever our sanctifying Grace
and and then we're really lost and then
it becomes much easier to just fall into
those habits you say once you start
doing some bad stuff then you end up
going really far you know in for a penny
in for a pound uh right that that's
because you You' severed that that kind
of Grace uh so you need to go to the
sacraments to restore that uh like the
laundromat for your soul uh but but
there's another kind of Grace which is
actual Grace which is which refers to
acts you know you think of actual Grace
that doesn't come from within you that
comes from God and it's it's God giving
us the grace to overcome whatever trials
are before us totally outside of
ourselves so a good example of this is
Saul on the road to Damascus gets
knocked off his horse that would be a
pretty clear example of actual Grace and
you can uh request that of God and if
you have Avail yourself of the
sacraments and you have sanctifying
Grace then you you can perhaps remind
God you're really just reminding
yourself but but you can articulate this
that that God promises you the the grace
to overcome these habits and these these
vices and sins uh some more quotidian
kind of advice for this if there's a sin
that you commit regularly you know you
uh Doom scroll when you're sitting on
this one part of the couch don't sit on
that part of the couch if you get really
really angry uh be when I don't know
when
your wife does something that you
observe then don't be in the room when
she does that thing or politely ask her
not to do that or something what
whatever it is whatever sets you off
don't put yourself in the near occasion
of sin You by by doing so you are in in
large part culpable for then falling
into the sin uh and and just Avail
yourself of those sacraments and be very
clear and pray all the time you know
prayer is not a last resort it's a first
Resort as my friend Father father
Benedict key points out so pray you know
when you when you would otherwise be
sinning you pray pray a rosary you know
I'm not saying it's
easy virtue is difficult to cultivate
Vice is easy to cultivate and hard to
fall out of and you can't do it on your
own anyway you know you you you actually
do need Graces sacramental and actual so
you are availing yourself of them to
some degree uh do it more so and then
don't despair I don't I don't want to
hear I know we shouldn't despair but
Nicks the butt that's a good first step
next
question hey Dr kof quick question for
you my wedding's coming up
on January
6th and I had a quick question for
you uh basic question is do you have any
advice for a newly wet couple thanks
love the
show I
well my advice would be to take the
wedding seriously and you already are
because you've picked a hilarious date
for your wedding so clearly you are
being intentional about it yes my advice
is actually first pertaining to the
wedding that you you recognize that the
wedding is your first act as a married
couple it's going to set the tone for
your marriage so if if the way you're
treating your wedding is oh my wife is
just going to do everything and I'll
just show up maybe on the day I I don't
know that that's a great way to start
your marriage I'm not saying you're
doing that but I know a lot of of people
do if your wedding is oh well I'll let
my mother-in-law do everything I don't
know is that how do you want do you want
your mother-in-law doing everything in
your whole marriage probably not that
would be my first advice Drew gave me
two pieces of good advice when I got
married first one is to have a good
marriage don't sleep with other people
step one step two throw feminism out the
window just throw it out it's bad it's
poison it's totally fake it will make
both of you miserable throw that out and
you know just be
normal that's that next one good morning
Michael this is Arun so I am an
assiduous follower of your Instagram
feed and therefore I can wish you uh a a
happy return to the United States after
your time in India you seem to have a
great time there by the way you rock to
Kura and I have a question for you based
on your recent travels to my ancestral
Homeland sadly also the ancestral
homeland of uh kamla Harris but you know
let's not talk about that maybe uh I am
curious if you share my particular Vice
for American fast food in India now I
know that this is probably blasphemy
against the culinary Gods right I mean
when in Rome do as the Romans when I go
to India I should be eating Indian food
and and to be clear there is a lot of
excellent food in India that is native
to India but as you've probably noticed
everything in India just tastes better I
I can't explain it but that appears to
be the case and that includes the
American fast food in my experience you
know I love going to McDonald's and
having uh their ALU Masala Burger
especially since you know I'm a Hindu
Brahman and therefore don't eat any meat
uh that's the only time I can have a
burger at McDonald's uh you know Burger
King has this this great uh paneer Tika
burger and Pizza Hut has a paneer Masala
cheese pizza it's it's just unlike
anything you'd ever get in the United
States and I am curious if you have
engaged in any kind of foray into
American fast food in India and and of
course because this is the Michael nuls
show I have to ask a philosophical
question as well a moral question really
and that is do you think that it is
right to go to another country and eat
American fast food instead of indulging
in their Cuisine and experiencing it
firsthand I'm curious as to your
thoughts on the matter thank you as
always for your
wisdom yes I think it's a good thing to
do that I did not have enough time on
this trip to India to indulge in
McDonald's and Pizza Hut there though my
Indian buddy assured me of this very
same thing he said he said McDonald's in
India is amazing you could you could
take a woman on a date there you know
it's really MC McDonald's in India is
delicious Fast Pizza Hut same thing I
didn't have time to do it it was kind of
a busy trip obviously trying to pursue
my dream of being a sitarist but I think
it's I think it is good my stepbrother
will he travels all over he will send me
pictures of him eating Burger King in
different countries because it's
it's enlightening in that you are
learning something about the culture
there even even in their interpretation
of American fast food you are learning
something not about America necessarily
but about that indigenous culture so I
think it's great you should try the the
local fair too but trying American fast
food in other countries is a great
little trick of travel okay next
question hey there Smokey Mike I've come
on to an idea that I think many would
consider to be too anachronistic but I
think in principle is perfectly
reasonable I think that dueling should
be legalized and though I do think it
should be constrained by the legal
system and there should be standards
applied to it I do think that the
satisfaction of a duel at least
certainly to the first Blood maybe not
to the death is perfectly justifiable if
there are legal constraints put on it
and it doesn't devolve into vigilantism
or other chaotic and unjust violence I
do think that if there is reason and
Justice applied to a duel it could be
perfectly reasonable and just and I do
think that well I certainly don't
believe that there is a political will
to have any change in this direction I
do think that dueling should be
legalized anyway I was hoping I get your
thoughts and thank you I'm afraid I have
to disagree because you say you don't
want it to devolve into vigilantism it
it is a type of vigilantism it it it is
taking the satisfaction of Justice
outside of the Civil Authority so that's
why dueling has always been
illegal and even where dueling itself is
not illegal it the the consequences of
dueling are illegal you know killing
someone attacking someone that has
always been illegal so it was always
outside of the justice system uh and it
would be very difficult to circumscribe
dueling as you as you say you know to
First Blood but not to death well what
if you just shoot the guy you blow his
head off you say there's the first Blood
oops guess that led to death too I I
would not recommend that I I do think we
should have a culture of honor and I
think people should be more polite and
they should be worried you know if you
walk up to someone in a bar and insult
his mother uh you should you should
expect to uh you know not just get a
Stern talking to as a consequence of
that but uh no I wouldn't recommend
getting rid of the legal system okay I
want to get to one written mailbag
before we get
to uh the mem room segmentum this is
from Jess hey Michael is believing in
racial stereotypes inherently racist not
the modern definition of racist but the
traditional one when I say stereotypes I
don't mean condescending ones for
example black people or athletic and
Jewish people are financially
responsible thanks
I no it's not I guess it's technically
racist in the sense that it acknowledges
distinctions between races of people uh
but it's not racist in the sense that
it's not not evil or cruel or you know
unjust or anything like that all
stereotypes are true this I guess this
is sort of Politically Incorrect you're
not allowed to say it today but it's
it's just a truism all stereotypes are
true that's how they became stereotypes
okay it doesn't mean that uh one ought
to deny people's individuality doesn't
mean that we ought to treat people
unjustly based on a stereotype but
stereotypes are true because or
stereotypes are are around because they
are true because they speak to something
that is true so there's nothing wrong
with that whether it's the positive ones
or the negative ones or whatever that's
not what would be wrong would be to
treat someone unjustly based based upon
your frequen Notions of his race or or
any other category that he falls in but
to say uh no no no stereotypes are true
oh yes no absolutely I think that uh you
know the the Vietnamese are just as good
at basketball as African American people
are no of course what are you talking
about no no no what do you mean no of
course this race or that race no of
course all stereotypes are true of
course it's okay you're you're allowed
to say it you were allowed to say it
even 20 years ago I don't know if you're
allowed to say it anymore but we still
say true things I think it's good to say
true things I think Clarity is Charity
as a Palam mine says the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code nolles
a check out for two months free on all
annual plans if you are not a
member then I suppose this is the last
time I'll I'll be chatting with you
before Christmas Eve and Christmas day
so I hope you've all had a blessed
Advent and have a very Merry Christmas
and if you are a member of the M
segmentum I'll see you in just a
[Music]
moment